thanks kendall who wouldn't like to have
more energy reduce swelling improved
immune function sleep better those are
just a few benefits from manual
lymphatic drainage treatment and here to
tell us more about this amazing
technique is the owner of lymphatic
organic reyna o'neal and ceo heidi otero
welcome you guys thank you so much if i
didn't do this myself i don't know if i
would have actually believed it it is an
amazing treatment um rayna why don't you
tell us a little bit about what the
lymphatic system kind of controls in the
body okay so basically the lymphatic
system i like to relate it to the sewer
or septic system in your body it's in
charge of getting rid of all the toxins
waste fluids everything out so it's
almost one of the most important things
inside of your body to regulate all
those things and heidi we get blockages
in our body how do these blockages
happen and how does lymphatic drainage
treatment get rid of those so just like
in your septic system at home it can be
a bunch of different things it can be
things that you use things that you
ingest the atmosphere all kinds of
things like that
and then the way that we help is with
our hands and with other tools we
manually remove these blockages out so
that you can remove the toxins and it's
quite a process and i actually love the
process
can you kind of talk about what what
happens when you get this treatment done
sure absolutely so the first thing we do
is some vibrational therapy your
lymphatic system doesn't have a pump to
it so the best way to activate it is
some type of vigorous exercise and
because we're not able to actually get
you to go outside and run we put you on
a vibrational plate to kind of start the
process after that we use sound therapy
again to clear any blockages that might
possibly be there and then we put you in
an infrared sauna along with a castor
oil and magnesium wrap to be able to
help start the sweating process as well
too and then we do the manual lymphatic
drainage and that is a really uh amazing
because
like when i had it you found a blockage
under my arm which is pretty common and
you just kind of worked that out we saw
some of the pictures i don't know if we
can get some of these back up before and
after treatments it's pretty incredible
after one treatment the difference these
are all one treatments and
this this isn't something where i drink
a and this is not me by the way i wish
it was
something where i drank a glass of water
and everything came back that was
absolutely incredible but it's actually
really good the benefits for your health
internally can you tell us about some of
those benefits yeah absolutely we always
show the before and after pictures
because it's the easiest way for us to
kind of like show the difference
visually but you're going to have
increased energy better sleep your
digestion is going to improve clears
your skin a lot of people just tell us
that you know they originally come to us
for the way it makes them look but then
they come back to us continuously for
the way it makes them feel because
that's really what's most important for
sure i've noticed a difference ever
since i went and it's it's absolutely
incredible more energy how do people get
in touch with you if they want to check
it out we do everything through
instagram as of right now it's just
lymphatic underscore organic
on there there's a booking and then we
have our contact information on there as
well too excellent thank you guys so
much thank you for letting me